[Musique]
mieux on débat sur france 24 consacrait
au blocus sur les céréales en mer noire
de la russie alors que les prix des
denrées alimentaires explose et que
l'onu évoque des risques de famine dans
les pays pauvres sergueï lavrov a
rencontré son homologue turc à ankara
l'enjeu est celui de la mise en place de
corridors sécurisés afin de permettre
les exportations de céréales
l'ukrainienne via la mer noire à l'issue
de cette rencontre la russie s'est dit
prête à garantir la sécurité des navires
céréaliers quittant les ports ukrainiens
avec la coopération la turquie mais sans
annoncer de mécanismes propres à
rassurer kiev la turquie juge quand elle
légitime la demande de la russie de
lever les sanctions appliquées aux
exportations agricoles russe à la
demande des nations unies ankara en tout
cas proposé son aide pour escorter les
convois céréales une arme pour la russie
on en débat avec mes invités j'ai
plaisir d'avoir mes côtés mathieu à
brens bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
directeur scientifique de la fondation
farm codirecteur avec sébastien abis de
l'édition 2022 du rapport demeter
alimentation les nouvelles frontières
c'est un ouvrage de référence sur les
enjeux stratégiques de l'agriculture et
de l'alimentation bienvenue à vous en
face de vous dit des billons bonsoir
bonsoir est directeur adjoint de l'iris
est également spécialiste de la turquie
bienvenue à vous nous avons par skype de
montpellier irène tall ray bonsoir à
vous bon soit eurodéputés renew europe
vous avez publié une tribune dans le
monde justement qui concerne notre sujet
nous avons avec nous à ankara ludovic le
foucault notre correspondant turquie
ludovic bonsoir
bonsoir bonsoir à tous et puis sachez
que vous pouvez tous réagir sur les
réseaux sociaux avec notre hashtag débat
f24
sergueï lavrov et son homologue turc je
vous le disais un mevlut cavusoglu se
sont donc vus à ankara la russie se dit
prête maintenant à garantir la sécurité
des navires céréaliers qui quitteraient
les ports d'ukrainiens avec la
coopération de la turquie la turquie
juge légitime la demande de la russie de
lever les sanctions appliquées aux
exportations agricoles russes ont fait
le point en images avec inès à la gare
aille
dans cette crise des céréales la turquie
veut jouer un rôle de médiateur pour
faire sortir les 30 millions de tonnes
de céréales bloqué en ukraine elle se
dit prête à mettre en place un corridor
maritime comme le souhaitent les nations
d'une
nous pouvons mettre en place un
mécanisme
collaboration entre rennes et la russie
et la turquie pour appliquer ce plan
la turquie pense que ce plan est
réalisable
en visite à ankara le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères assure que moscou
est prête à participer et affirme que
son armée ne profitera pas de la sortie
des bateaux ukrainien pour attaquer nous
sommes prêts à garantir la sécurité des
navires qui quittent les ports
ukrainiens
et nous le ferons en coopération avec
nos collègues du
cpar odessa que transite la grande
majorité des céréales ukrainienne mais
mardi encore le président zelensky se
refusait à déminer les autour de ce port
par crainte que les forces russes ne
s'infiltre dans la brèche avant
l'invasion russe le 24 février l'ukraine
exportées chaque mois 12% du blé mondial
15% du maïs et 50% de l'huile de
tournesol après trois mois de guerre la
flambée des prix fait désormais peser un
grave risque de famine dans les pays qui
dépendent de ces céréales de chrétiennes
comme en afrique ou au moyen-orient
ludovic ludwig de foucauld puisque vous
êtes à ankara vous avez suivi
attentivement cette rencontre à ce qu'on
peut dire que c'est un succès est-ce
qu'il va y avoir des corridors
c'est un succès si on écoute le ministre
turc des affaires étrangères qui s'est
montré extrêmement optimiste qui s'est
félicité d'une rencontre est très
fructueuse qui s'est montré confiant en
un futur mécanisme inédit que tout était
faisable et il a dit qu'il n'avait pas
senti une atmosphère aussi positive
depuis longtemps qu'il était sûr que
désormais et dans peu de temps les
parties ukrainiennes et russes eux
pourraient se rencontrer en turquie
grâce à la turquie dont il a vanté le
rôle facilitateur mais voilà il a dit
que tout était faisable que les
propositions turc était faisable le
déminage en mer noire le fait de dégager
des couloirs maritimes le fait
d'installer un centre d'observation en
coordination avec l'onu à istanbul et il
a dit aussi ça ça a été un peu plus
étonnant que si le monde voulait éviter
une crise alimentaire mondiale alors il
fallait aussi se pencher sur la question
de lever les obstacles aux exportations
russes côté russe sergueï lavrov lui a
jeté un froid en dix ans selon lui on ne
peut pas dire que la situation causera
une crise alimentaire il a aussi dit
nous n'avons jamais fait obstacle au
passage de bateaux le déminage est un
problème mineur nous sommes tout à fait
disposés à aller de l'avant avec ce
projet mais ce sont les ukrainiens qui
le bloc qui n'arrête pas de changer
d'avis la balle est dans leur camp la
crainte de la russie c'est que si des
couloirs maritimes sont dégagés les
bateaux qui arriveraient sur les côtes
du chrétienne pour se charger en blé est
en fait n'arriverait pas vide il
arriverait l'ecal chargé d'armes et puis
la crainte et des ukrainiens évidemment
c'est que si déminage il y avait bien la
russie en profiteraient directement pour
tenter une attaque pour tenter un
débarquement peu avant la rencontre le
ministre créneau affaires étrangères
avait déjà dit que les mots de poutine
était vide et qu'on ne pouvait pas avoir
confiance en lui merci ludovic on va
bien non qu'un que ça va être à la
discussion de deux ce soir puisque selon
ces deux pays finalement la balle est
dans le camp à des ukrainiens et selon
volodymyr élève qui entre 20 et 25
millions de tonnes de céréales sont
bloqués une quantité qui pourrait
d'ailleurs augmenté on va écouter à le
président ukrainien
vous savez si maintenant nous avons
environ 22 à 25 millions de tonnes
bloqué à l'automne cela pourrait être 75
millions de tonnes
mathieu bras vous qui êtes dire
spécialistes de toutes ces questions de
céréales avant conflit kiev exportées
chaque mois 12% blé mondial 15% du maïs
et 50 % d'huile de tournesol on voit que
moscou et kiev s'accusent mutuellement
de détruire les stocks de céréales on va
regarder tout de suite une carte une
carte qui montre que les navires russes
bloque les exportations de céréales
ukrainienne en mer noire est ce qu'on
peut dire lorsqu'on voit cette carte que
vladimir poutine exerce un chantage
alimentaire
cela dit mir poutine effectivement
depuis le début de l'invasion de de
l'ukraine exerce ce chantage alimentaire
qui peut être aussi très risqué pour lui
en bloquant les exportations de céréales
ukrainienne depuis le début il ya plus
de céréales qui sortent des ports
ukrainiens alors que les réalités venu
de sortir c'est us est une réalité on a
quand même le président de l'avenir
reims qui l'a rappelé 25 millions de
tonnes qui sont encore dans les dents
les réserves en sachant que la récolte
va commencer dans quelques semaines et
que encore beaucoup vendre à un bon
arriver donc on va avoir un problème de
place très rapidement c'était avec les
fermiers craignant n'arrive plus à les
stocker dire que les récoltes qui vont
arriver on va on va commencer avec dans
quelques semaines en ukraine le blé mais
on pourra pas remplir des cellules qui
sont déjà pleins donc il va y avoir des
enjeux extrêmement important et et les
céréales l on donne est stocké dans des
très très bonnes conditions l'on
surveille la ventilation l'humidité les
risques aussi sanitaire donc s'il ya pas
de place ça veut dire qu'on ne pourra
pas les stocker nom qu'on pourra pas les
vendre et elles risquent d'être perdus
et bien pour rebondir ce qu'a dit sur ce
qu'a dit ludovic a obtenu finalement la
turquie des russes pas grand chose
c'était fructueux cette rencontre mais
c'est tout à fait positif pour la
turquie on se souvient que un mois juste
après le début de la guerre c'était le
24 mars très exactement la turquie avait
déjà réussi dans le cadre du forum
diplomatique d'antalya de réunir les
ministres des affaires étrangères turc
eu bien sûr
russes et ukrainiens
donc c'était un à une avancée
diplomatique parce que la turquie son
obsession c'est de se placer au centre
du jeu et de montrer qu'elle est
absolument incontournable
aujourd'hui mission réussie même si ici
on réussit mais quels sont les résultats
finalement à quelles conditions ces
corridors peuvent-ils ou vente il
existait mais évidemment mais vu la
situation qui prévaut aujourd'hui entre
les deux pays vu la situation de guerre
il aurait fallu être un petit peu naïve
pour considérer qu'en 24 heures on
puisse tout régler donc moi ce qui me
paraît essentiel c'est que le contact
n'est pas été rompu avec une lance
d'importance et que la partie
ukrainienne n'était pas présente donc
maintenant il n'ya rien de plus urgent
que de faire une réunion à minima
tripartite et sous l'égide de l'onu ça
c'est la prochaine étape qui apparemment
a recueilli l'accord et des turcs et des
russes aujourd'hui même de monsieur
chavo chauloux et de monsieur lavrov
c'est à dire qu on accepte que l'onu met
en oeuvre j'espère dans les meilleurs
délais un système permettant
l'acheminement des céréales ukrainien
vers istanbul et donc vers la
méditerranée ensuite donc là vous dites
la balle est dans le camp d'espagne à
rabat absolument mais encore faut-il
leur donner la possibilité de participer
à part pleine et entière aux digues aux
négociations irez vous êtes d'accord
avec ce que vient de dire didier billion
vous écrivez dans une tribune du monde
poutine utilise la famine pour renforcer
le chaos créé par la guerre qu'il a
lancée contre l'ukraine oui et
tout d'abord par rapport à la
désinformation russe
l'union européenne ne fait absolument
pas aucune sanction qui empêchent les
exportations de blé et ne laisser des
sanctions qui touchent le secteur du
transport le le tout se passe en dehors
de l'union européenne donc si la russie
veut débloquer du blé elle peut le faire
donc il faut faire très attention union
européenne est au rendez vous depuis le
début et il faut aider les ukrainiens à
manger les ukrainiens à se défendre et
l'ensemble des personnes qui ont touché
donc moi je suis plutôt sur quelque
chose autour de l'eau et nuque une
confiance aveugle sur quelqu'un qui
utilise depuis le début avec des
destructions d'infrastructures
logistiques ça va mettre du temps à être
reconstruit
donc je ne crois pas forcément à à ce
qui se passe en ce moment la russie a
d'ailleurs minimisé le rôle un de son
offensive en ukraine dans la flambée des
cours des céréales on va écouter tout de
suite dmitri peskov le porte parole
il ne faut pas exagérer l'importance de
l' influence sur les marchés
internationaux des réserves de céréales
l'ukrainienne
c'est un trop petit pourcentage pour
avoir un impact significatif sur la
crise alimentaire mondiale qui a déjà
commencé
mathieu dit vrai mettez pas ce kof non
non il faut aussi dit phocéen c'est un
porte parole on a une situation
extrêmement catastrophique qui n'a pas
commencé avec l'invasion de la de la
deûle et crennes par la russie puisqu'il
y avait d'autres éléments qui ont fait
remonter les prix des matières premières
notamment les engrais mais aussi les
chocs climatiques et les chocs
économiques par contre et qu'on a quand
même 25 millions de tonnes qui ne vont
pas aller sur les marchés et ça entraîne
des derniers développements des des gros
des grosses eu d'augmentation des prix
ça a des conséquences sur les sur les
prix des marchés internationaux et c'est
bien là qu'est le problème le problème
de pénurie il est moins direct mais par
contre la conséquence sur les marchés et
donc sur la capacité de pays comme
l'egypte le maroc la tunisie et d'autres
pays en afrique subsaharienne macky sall
à la rappeler une situation très
préoccupante leur capacité d'acheter les
matières premières agricoles comme le
blé les huiles végétales et là par
contre remise en question donc ce n'est
pas tant une une question de de stocks
et de pénurie que de prix des marchés
internationaux et de projection dans
l'est dans les prochains mois selon
l'onu plus de 100 millions de personnes
auront besoin d'une aide alimentaire
d'urgence dans le monde en 2022 donc là
l'onu parle de pénurie quelque part
l'onu parle de sécurité alimentaire et
d'insécurité alimentaire n'oublions pas
que la première des causes de
l'insécurité alimentaire c'est la
capacité économique des gens et c'est ce
qu'on rappelle au sein de la fondation
farm la capacité économique des gens
d'acheter la nourriture les prix
flambent mai
il flambe sur toutes les matières
premières y compris les huiles végétales
huile de palme locales dans en afrique
de l'ouest le blé le maïs etc donc c'est
patent vraiment la dimension de la
quantité disponible on produit
normalement assez de nourriture sur la
planète c'est un problème d'allocation
et de prix avant tout parce que didier
billion à ce que finalement la russie
n'utilise pas cette arme comme une autre
arme c'est une arme vraiment larmes
alimentaire vous le dire c'est bien
évidemment en fait cette question
alimentaire dont on parle aujourd'hui
concentre tous les enjeux politiques
diplomatiques et voire militaires que
nous connaissons et que le peuple
ukrainien a subi depuis maintenant plus
de trois mois c'est à dire que tous les
moyens sont bons c'est terrible à dire
mais c'est assis nous sommes dans une
guerre une guerre c'est toujours
beaucoup de dégâts et donc la russie ce
qui a quand même quelques difficultés
d'ordre militaire chacun l'a compris qui
risque d'avoir dans les mois à venir des
difficultés économiques accepte de jouer
un jeu politique et diplomatique comme
on l'a vu aujourd'hui mais il est clair
et là je suis d'accord avec la députée
il faut des garanties et les seules
garanties qui ne sont jamais absolu mais
dont on peut se douter c'est de remettre
l'eau est venue au centre du jeu
internationaux elle l'avait déjà fait
des tentatives de médiation 2 me
semble-t-il oui pour l'instant ça n'a
rien donné mais il ne vous a pas échappé
que monsieur buts et res le secrétaire
général de l'onu a mis près de trois
mois se rendre en ukraine et en russie
c'est une erreur c'est une faute
politique il n'y avait pour lui rien de
plus urgent en tant que secrétaire
général que de se précipiter ou d'aller
rapidement la précipitation est toujours
mauvaise conseillère médias lite le plus
rapidement possible en russie et en
ukraine mans on va pas pleurer sur ce
qui n'a pas été fait matin il faut se
projeter vers l'avenir partir et
s'appuyer sur ce qui s'est dit
aujourd'hui à ankara pour comme d'un
levier pour aller plus loin il resterait
cette guerre est ce qu'elle détruit
aussi finalement l'ukraine
économiquement est ce que ce blocus est
une arme aussi contre l'ukraine pour
l'affaiblir économiquement bien sûr et
c'est pour ça que
[Musique]
aide l'ukraine sur tous les sujets y
compris pour pouvoir continuer à la
pouvoir faire les futures récoltes
récoltés et voir y compris à avoir une
façon de de sortir ces céréales de
russie par des voies non maritimes qui
sont pas du tout efficace donc c'est
vrai que les voies maritimes ce serait
la solution mais aujourd'hui on ne les a
pas donc oui il ya une volonté de
détruire l'ukraine économiquement il ya
aussi une volonté de déstabiliser
l'union européenne politiquement en
ayant dans ses flots de réfugiés cette
hausse des prix alimentaires qui touche
aussi les et les populations en europe
et donc c'est important qu'on soit au
rendez-vous de la duc rényon mais aussi
de l'aide de l'union européenne et en
dehors de l'union européenne pour passer
cette période troublée tous ensemble on
va y revenir d'ailleurs là une question
donc sur twitter de franck et mais quels
seraient les retombées économiques de
l'établissement de ces corridors pour
l'ukraine vous avez peut-être la réponse
alors les retombées économiques précis
ce serait difficile de les citer mais
pour aller dans le sens de madame la
députée on a quand même une région le
donbass qui produisait 40% du blé
ukrainien dont on parle de d'armes
alimentaire et et vladimir poutine a
vraiment développé cet atout qu'est
l'agriculture il asphyxie l'économie
ukrainienne parce que c'est une partie
très importante de son pib qui provient
de l'agriculture ne pouvons pas exporter
ce sont pas de rentrées de devises
étrangères pas de capacités aussi à
produire beaucoup d'infrastructures qui
sont détruites donc si on se projette
aussi dans le temps à l'horizon
peut-être de l'année prochaine ou des
deux campagnes prochaine on aura aussi
des risques très importants sur
l'économie ukrainienne et puis
n'oublions pas quand même que l'une des
premières victimes de cette crise
alimentaire ou de cette famine ou de 7,1
alimentaire c'est le peuple ukrainien
lui même qui aura aussi des difficultés
à se nourrir c'est le peuple iranien et
puis ce sont effectivement les pays
d'afrique didier billion on sait que
macky sall est allé voir justement à
vladimir poutine il y à il ya quelques
jours le président sénégalais dont qui a
reconnu qu'il fallait que la russie
fasse quelque chose pour l'afrique et
vladimir poutine qui a d'ailleurs dit
qu'il était le protecteur de ses
différents pays mais pour l'instant pour
l'instant le risque c'est tout de même
une pénurie en afrique bien évidemment
il ya un enjeu en tant que tel
alimentaires non seulement pour les
peuples les plus directement concernés à
commencer par le peuple ukrainien mais
aussi en partie pour l'union européenne
est évidemment moyen-orient afrique
subsaharienne c'est une certitude mais
j'insiste sur un point c'est quand macky
sall s'est rendu à moscou pour
rencontrer vladimir poutine il y allait
pas seulement en tant que sénégalais il
y aller en tant que responsable de
l'union africaine et la signification
politique parce qu'il faut toujours
replacer dans le contexte c'est
qu'aujourd'hui une grande partie des
populations de la planète et notamment
ce qu'on appelle les populations des
pays émergents où les pays du sud et je
mets des guillemets à ces expressions
aujourd'hui ont condamné l'agression
russe mais se refuse à appliquer les
sanctions contre la russie est donc là
on revient sur le terrain politique
parce que bien sûr au delà de la stricte
question alimentaire qui est importante
en tant que telle il ya les enjeux
politiques est ce que la majorité des
pays de la planète sont derrière les
décisions de l'union européenne et des
états unis de sanctions contre la russie
eh bien non alors on peut le regretter
on peut le condamner mais c'est un fait
donc il faudra aussi que les européens
les dirigeants de l'union européenne
la représentation parlementaire
européenne prenne conscience de cet
aspect des choses nous ne sommes pas
seuls au monde et les occidentaux ne
peuvent pas imposer leurs desiderata au
reste de la planète et rental rêvait
peut-être réagir sur ce que vient de
dire didier billion c'est vrai que macky
sall et un certain nombre d'autres pays
d'ailleurs sont contre ces sanctions
puisqu'ils disent que ça ne fait
qu'empirer les choses sur en
l'occurrence sur la lancée ou céréales
et autres je répète que la russie a eu
tout à fait aujourd'hui y'a pas de
prennent de pénurie de stocker donc si
la russie veut fournir l'afrique je
crois qu'elle peut le faire on a un
moment donné un outil politique qui est
aussi un outil politique deux stades de
déstabilisation de l'union européenne
n'y a pas eu de sanctions qui empêche la
russie de faire quoi que ce soit au
niveau des stocks agricoles donc faut
pas exagérer par contre l'union
européenne elle est solidaire de pro de
deux pays qui sont européens de deux
cultures qui va leur entrée dans l'union
européenne et c'est notre grandeur je
crois d'être au rendez vous ça veut pas
dire que on impose notre règle au reste
du monde mais on défend nous nos amis
ukrainiens l'univers craag nous a
rejoint notre correspondant de france 24
à kiev d'univers bonsoir
la russie d'après ce qu'on lit donc on
parle d'armes alimentaire on en a parlé
sur ce plateau elles utilisent cette
arme alimentaire un chantage alimentaire
même et bien aujourd'hui on voit qu'elle
vole même des céréales l'ukrainienne qui
seraient bloqués pour les vendre à son
propre profit gulliver on parle même de
trois cargos qui ont été repérés à
sébastopol en crimée en train de charger
des céréales considéré comme voler et à
des cargos d'ailleurs livré à les livrer
sa cargaison au régime syrien allié de
moscou vous avez des informations est
reçue effectivement la russie vol une
partie des céréales les ukrainiennes
pour les vendre à bas prix
oui ce qu'on veut dire quand on accuse
la russie de voler ses cargos et c'est
bien le mot qui est employé par les
autorités ukrainiennes c'est que la
russie prend des céréales cultivées dont
les territoires de l'ukraine qu'elle
occupe en ce moment et dans certains cas
on ne sait pas exactement quelles sont
les conditions financières imposées aux
agriculteurs dans ces régions mais je
pense qu'elles sont très très
désavantageuse et puis bien sûr aucun
impôt n'est payée à l'état ukrainien
c'est juste la russie qui prend ses
céréales les agriculteurs les
producteurs ils ont vraiment pas le
choix vu que c'est l'armée russe qui
occupe ses terres en fait quand j'étais
dans la région d'odessa hier j'ai
j'étais avec un agriculteur dans la
région d'odessa loeb qui n'est pas
occupé qui parlait avec un ami qui est
dans la région de zaporijia qui est
occupé et qui lui demandait alors que
bouffon les rues c'est ce qu' ils
prennent votre grain et l'autre
agriculteurs qui répondait au téléphone
c'était en haut parleur il disait que
oui en payons à peu près le tiers du
prix normal le prix du marché donc vous
voyez pourquoi les ukrainiens estiment
que le mot juste à employer pour ces cas
c'est bien le paul mathieu bras donc
vous vous êtes d'accord avec ce que
vient de dire gulliver donc on parle de
ces trois cargos donc un des cargos qui
aurait livré sa cargaison au régime
syrien allié on parle également d'après
le new york times un de diplomates
américains qui aurait prévenu 14 pays
même que trois cargos russes qui
transportent des céréales ukrainiennes
allaient justement être et bien des
versets ont dû à des pays africains qui
vont être mis devant un dilemme est ce
que les pays africains vont se rendre
complices de ce pillage ou pas on a vu
sur sur les médias les réseaux sociaux
des des ports des tournées en egypte
certains arrivés vers le liban puis
lattaquié en syrie on est bien dans une
situation où ces pays là ont aussi
besoin d'avoir de recevoir le blé dont
ils ont besoin pour nourrir leur
population en particulier les
populations urbaines en afrique
subsaharienne dont il ya effectivement
un risque de deux de se voir un petit
peu tordre le bras en fait quels choix
ont-ils au final de ne pas accepter ces
livraisons de céréales même si elles ont
été effectivement volé et ça ça ne fait
quasiment aucun doute comme comme l'a
rappelé votre correspondant
manifestement les russes vendre à leurs
profils allant du paon qui serait payant
dans les régions ukrainienne unian mais
on peut peut-être je ne sais pas mais on
peut même d'après certaines informations
considéré que ce n'est pas simplement
trois cargos que depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines passent par le
détroit du bosphore et des dardanelles
donc les détroits qui sont ce contrôle
des drames turquie et que la turquie est
parfaitement courant mais que la turquie
pour des raisons politiques ne veut pas
se brouiller totalement avec moscou cela
laisse passer ces navires est ce qu'elle
a toujours peur on avait l'impression
qu'au départ elle ne le souhaitait pas à
l'aîné s'est passé dans ce qu'elle a dit
très clairement et très rapidement c'est
qu'elle a bloqué les détroits comme la
convention de montreux de 1936 l'y
autorise à la bloquer le passage des
navires de militaires de guerre russe ça
c'est clair et net et depuis lors aucun
n'est passé mais les navires civils les
cargos par exemple saharien ne
l'empêchent alors elle pourrait les
blocs les mais elle ne le fait pas parce
que autre dossier qui a été dans les
discussions aujourd'hui même entre
lavrov et son homologue shah bouchard
loup c'est la question de la syrie
puisqu'on parle par ailleurs beaucoup
d'une intervention militaire turque dans
le nord de la syrie et que pour ce faire
il ya besoin de l'aval de la russie donc
qui a un jeu de billard à trois bandes
qui est terrible kaki la realpolitik à
l'état brute s'est ainsi donc vous voyez
que c'est à dire les turcs disent je
laisse passer vos bateaux plein de
céréales ukrainien ukrainienne à
condition que vous me laissiez envahir
le nord de la syrie sans comme ça c'est
un peu ça c'est sûrement un peu plus
compliqué mais les sens schématiquement
c'est un peu ça en tout cas on sent
qu'il ya une sorte de négociations entre
les deux c'est ce que vous dites presque
c'est presque oui
troyer de comme on dit en anglais je
rajoutais simplement que la turquie ne
l'espace juste passer des bateaux
remplis de deblé elle en achètent
énormément à la russie elle a une
dépendance très forte vis-à-vis de la
russie et du blé ukrainien pour ses
approvisionnements en blé et on sait
bien que plus le prix du pain monte en
turquie plus la cote de popularité du
président on diminue et on est quand
même dans une année qui va être
électorale avec un enjeu très important
et je rajouterai aussi à cela donc elle
l'achète à quel prix d'ailleurs ce blé
je ne sais pas à quel prix à quel prix
elle elle l'achète si elle achète aussi
un prix beaucoup plus faible que ce qui
est que ce qu'il n'est mais en tout cas
elle a besoin de ce blé pour répondre à
la à la demande de sa population et la
turquie aussi un gros exportateur de
farine en particulier dans la région
afrique subsaharienne lanka des
dépendances très fortes aussi vis-à-vis
de la turquie est d'ailleurs au début de
la conférence de presse commune le
ministre lavrov le ministre des affaires
étrangères russe a pris un malin plaisir
à rappeler l'importance l'intensité des
relations économiques et commerciales
entre la russie et la turquie comme
d'une petite musique disons audio
écoutez ne nous ennuyer pas trop parce
que sinon on pourrait avoir des mesures
de rétorsion à votre égard il resterait
on voit bien tout de même cette espèce
de realpolitik entre la russie la
turquie et les européens eux finalement
quel rôle ont ils véritablement
lorsqu'il voit ce type de tractations
avoir lieu sous leurs yeux
on ne vous entend plus allez-y allez-y
l'union européenne a été au rendez vous
depuis le début pour aider l'ukraine bon
ça c'est un premier point il ya pas mal
d'argent qui a été mis sur la table au
jour d'aujourd'hui il faut aller plus
loin notamment avec l'initiative farm
porté par le président macro avec le g7
pour mettre un mécanisme financier qui
accompagne la localisation des stocks
que l'on connaît aujourd'hui à travers
un appel à miss de façon à ce que on
essaye de limiter la casse cependant par
rapport à la realpolitik
donc bon on parlait moi il me semble que
la russie a beau un beau rôle de parler
de ce qu'elle pourrait faire avec les
stocks de puisque c'est quand même elle
qui a créé le problème donc je crois que
par rapport à l'utilisation qui est
faite pour faire de la déstabilisation
politique par poutine qui va servir les
pays amis et créer des problèmes dans
les pays qui peut être qu'ils traitent
serait plus proche de la sphère
européenne il est important que l'union
européenne soit au rendez vous pour
aider les populations ukrainienne les
pays qui accueillent les flux de
réfugiés
les classes moyennes européennes et
après derrière que nous ayons des
actions à court terme mais aussi à moyen
terme et et structurelles pour arrêter
ses dépendances invraisemblable deux
pays qui dépendent à 90% des céréales et
irène faudrait en tout cas lorsque les
russes disent qu'il faut lever les
sanctions que l'europe doit lever les
sanctions et que c'est la condition pour
les russes justement de lever le blocus
sur les céréales l'ukrainienne il en est
pas question c'est inacceptable pour les
européens les céréales ne sont pas
sujettes donc il n'y a aucun problème
pour les russes ils ont ils peuvent y
aller ils peuvent les vendre n'est pas
rien par les autres mentions très facile
de se cacher derrière les sanctions la
réalité c'est que les sanctions ne
touche pas la nourriture est donc
aujourd'hui le pays qui créent le stress
c'est la russie d'univers gulliver craag
un mot peut-être sur les multitudes les
stratagèmes finalement pour sortir les
céréales d'ukraine parce que il y en a
un certain nombre alors effectivement on
va revoir la carte le blocus en mer
noire fait qu'on ne peut pas exporter
ses céréales de mer noire en revanche il
ya tout de même les ports fluviaux du
danube il ya une partie des exportations
qui sont redirigés effectivement aussi
par voie terrestre via la route le rail
alors on sait qu'un certain nombre
d'infrastructures ont été pilonnées par
les russes est ce que ça serait ce que
ce sont des possibilités d'acheminer
justement à les céréales ukrainienne
soit la voie terrestre soit les ports
fluviaux
amiens sont en train d'essayer de tenter
par tous les moyens possible d'exporter
leurs stocks de grains entre 20 et 30
millions des céréales sont actuellement
stockés en ukraine et la récolte va
commencer dans quelques semaines pendant
le mois de juin ils savent pas où les
stocker donc ils cherchent par tous les
moyens
mais même dans le meilleur des mondes
par exemple les chemins de fer
ukrainienne aurait dans le meilleur des
mondes une capacité possible de 18
millions de tonnes de céréales qu'il
pourrait exporter mais on n'est pas du
tout dans le meilleur des mondes parce
que les chemins de fer l'ukrainien ça
une largeur différentes que celui de
l'union européenne donc il faut
transférer les céréales dans des trains
européens à la frontière avec l'union
européenne et les pays de l'union
européenne n'ont pas du tout cette
capacité même pour atteindre c'est 18
millions qui est même pas le tiers de
toute façon des 60 millions que
l'ukraine pensée exporter cette année en
janvier avant le début de cette invasion
matière peut-être rebondir sur ce qui va
me dire gulliver on parle aussi
d'ailleurs du port roumain de constanta
passion de la mer noire ça serait aussi
une alternative une sorte de porte de
sortie aux produits ukrainien d'abord ce
que ce que ce que dit gulliver s'est
bien l'importance de des voies maritimes
80% du commerce agricole et de l'export
agricole de l'ukraine passe par les
voies maritimes il faut pas loin de 50
ou 60 trains c'est à dire un nombre
incalculable de wagons pour faire les 60
niveaux 70 mille tonnes d'un panamax ou
d'un bateau ça veut dire que même si on
avance très vite on restera au compte
gouttes et déjà eu quelques trains qui
vont circuler mais on ne pourra jamais
atteindre le même niveau surtout pour
vider comme je vous le disais c'est 20
millions de tonnes de stock alors oui il
existe des routes alternatives des
efforts qui ont été fournis par les
allemands pour construire des ponts des
ponts autour d'eux des ponts cette fois
ci avec avec des tringles le le port de
constanta en roumanie est une
alternative mais soyons réalistes déjà
il ya des difficultés pour satisfaire
l'export sur ce bord là qui est un des
ports les plus importants de au sein de
l'union européenne craint qu'un premier
navire a pris le large avec 70 mille
tonnes de maïs ukrainiens à bord ça
c'est au port de constanta un
progressivement se fait en avril autour
de la autour du port si le port peut
fonctionner bien il ya un problème de
logistique de flux c'est à dire 'est-ce
qu'on utilise les berges c'est à dire
les voies fluviales est ce qu'on utilise
les trains les routes c'est très
encombré n'y a pas beaucoup
d'infrastructures qui permet
d'accueillir un nombre extrêmement
important de trains de bateaux ou deux
barges et n'oublions pas non plus que la
roumanie est un gros exportateur de
deblé à l'export' aussi tout le blé des
pays aux alentours qui n'ont pas accès à
la mer ou pas accès aux voies maritimes
et donc il va falloir aussi répondre à
cette demande là donc on pourra pas à
moins d'investir énormément d'argent
mais le temps ne suffira pas développer
les infrastructures terrestres
logistique qui permettent d'acheminer au
fur et à mesure vers le port de
constanta et en même temps d'offrir les
capacités pour charger des bateaux ça
prend énormément de temps régulière cra
vouliez réagir et je voulais juste
souligner que je pense c'est ma mémoire
est bonne il faut au moins une quinzaine
sinon une vingtaine de barrages pour
faire un panama tous et peut-être même
plus et à chaque fois donc c'est une
transaction séparée c'est de la
bureaucratie c'est de la paperasse et
les entreprises ni les entreprises
ukrainien ni les entreprises roumaines
ou des autres pays non vraiment la
capacité de tous soudainement avoir
tellement plus de choses à gérer c'est
c'est juste aussi logistiquement
extrêmement difficile et puis aussi j'ai
parlé un exportateur en tout cas
ukrainien qui disait que ils ont
beaucoup de problèmes avec la
bureaucratie roumaine la roumanie qui
insiste encore pour que des contrôles
sanitaires soient passés à gala de savon
de pouvoir emmener les barges à
constanta pour que les céréales soient
transférés sur des bateaux plus grands
lui il disait qu'il y aurait des
améliorations à faire coter bureaucratie
en roumanie côté enlèvement des
certaines restrictions sanitaires etc
qui pourrait accélérer un petit peu le
processus mais de toute façon comme je
disais même dans le meilleur des mondes
on est vraiment très très loin
d'atteindre les volumes que l'ukraine
exporté d'habitude y rental ray donc il
y aura des progrès à faire tout de même
côté europe sur la bureaucratie sur
effectivement ont la taille des rails
c'est pas demain évidemment qu'elle va
changer mais est-ce qu effectivement il
pourrait y avoir que même des mesures
qui pourraient faciliter ces transports
oui à l'union européenne oui oui nous
nous travaillons dessus de travail dans
mon groupe politique là dessus donc on
pourrait envisager d'avoir des hub de
transbordement dans des frontières à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne pour
pouvoir déplacer à rythmes
à définir ce stock ukrainien et après le
renvoyer par au calme dans l'union
européenne il ya la nécessité de lever
les processus de contrôle puisque là on
est dans une entrée dans l'union donc de
mettre des procédures un petit peu
allégé pour pour que voilà que que ça
rentre on a aussi le problème comme vous
lui disiez des multiples transactions et
du fait que les sociétés ukrainiennes
les assurances ne les couvrent pas donc
on a aussi besoin d'avoir un système de
réassurance européen pour fluidifier les
échanges de marchandises et donc que ces
céréales puisse rentrer donc on
travaille là dessus un peu en mode co
vide c'est-à-dire le parlement en
anticipation en travail y compris avec
des ukrainiens les délais logistique ont
été multipliées avant un producteur
ukrainien s'est arrêté quelques heures
pour aller rejoindre la structure
d'export aujourd'hui on parle de
quasiment un mois donc ces problèmes
logistiques qui créent les pénuries sont
très importants ça veut aussi dire que
c'est une leçon pour l'union européenne
c'est que le risque géopolitique
1 il existe deux il est à nos portes et
3 il peut entraîner des crises
alimentaires donc on doit revoir nos
systèmes comme on l'a vu avec l'aco vide
pour être au rendez-vous de
l'alimentation qui est quand même une
attente majeure de tout être humain et
pour pouvoir contourner dans ce blocus
didier billion les biélorusses j'ai vu
qu'il y avait peut-être un transit
possible aussi à partir du nord de
l'ukraine c'est quelque chose qui
pourrait être plausible alors que
loukachenko a proposé d'ailleurs au
secrétaire général de l'onu de
transporter des céréales en échange
d'une levée partielle des sanctions
parce qu'évidemment il ne perd pas le
nord le président biélorusse mais vous
nous enfin toutes les solutions de
facilitation sont bons à prendre parce
qu'elles vont s'accumuler elles vont
donner des résultats pour autant nous
sommes très concrètement dans une
situation d' économie de guerre pour
nous cette expression est un peu
théorique un peu lointaines souvent on
en parle pour des pays qui se trouvent
dans d'autres continents eh bien nous le
vivons au sein de l'europe et de l'union
européenne et donc
faut faire assaut d'ingéniosité de
multiplier les initiatives les
inventions la créativité ça c'est très
bien mais pour autant a écouté avec
attention mais mêler mes collègues les
intervenants de ce plateau je pense que
je reviens au point de départ de notre
entretien et que clairement c'est là la
question politique qui doit se poser
avec les ukrainiens et avec les rues
c'est à dire faire que la réunion
d'aujourd'hui ne soit pas un coup dans
l'eau qu'elles se concrétisent parce que
nous savons que par la voie maritime
pour les raisons exposées ce sera la
véritable solution donc il faut faire
feu de tout bois si je vous me permettez
l'expression
mais il ne pas oublier la voie qui sera
la plus efficace la plus efficiente
c'est à dire la voie maritime et on va
voir justement à quelles conditions un
mot peut-être matthieu brasse sur les
ports de la baltique là aussi cela je
l'avais oubliée donc intéressant d'en
parler aussi la pologne la lituanie qui
a proposé de servir de relais pour les
exportations ukrainiennes même s'ils
sont loin des zones de stockage donc là
aussi ça serait compliqué ça sera
compliqué ce seront des sorties de ce2
de secours en fait qui seront
congestionné donc ce seront des petits
pansements à m à court terme mais je
rejoins complètement didier sur la
l'enjeu de libérer les voies maritimes
parce que si on lit par les voies
maritimes on libère les millions de
tonnes qui sont stockés le port de
libérer des volets voie maritime ça veut
dire lever le blocus russe il n'y a pas
d'eau de lever le blocus rue ça veut
dire aussi lever les foules et la
circulation des eaux maritimes donc les
mines des mines et ça aussi il faudra un
engagement de toutes les parties pour
pour le faire et à ce moment là quand on
pourra lever ces difficultés les prix
vont aussi s'atténue et c'est ça qui est
important aujourd'hui à au moins à moyen
terme justement gulliver gulliver craag
en fait qu'est ce que les ukrainiens
parce que manifestement les russes
demande aux ukrainiens de diminuer les
ports il demande d'ailleurs aussi un
contrôle des navires qui prendrait
la mer noire pour l'instant et l'ins qui
a l'air d'être totalement opposés à ce
type de conditions et puis ils demandent
aussi les russes donc une levée des
sanctions européennes on a bien vu toute
façon que ça c'était inacceptable donc
qu'est ce que pourraient faire les
ukrainiens pour avancer dans les
négociations
alors d'abord les ukrainiens accusent
les russes d'avoir miné la merde avoir
reposé ses mines demeurent l'ukraine ni
avoir posé des mines dans la mer elle
dit avoir posé des mines sur le littoral
est mis en place d'autres systèmes de
défense je ne sais pas aux réalités sont
peu leur croire sur parole mais ce qui
est sûr c'est que les ukrainiens sont
absolument convaincus et pour cause
qu'ils ne peuvent pas croire la russie
sur parole alors aucune garanties
verbales même signé qui serait proposée
par la russie ne suffira pour l'ukraine
elle veut un accompagnement un militaire
sécuritaire pour les navires est aussi
une garantie vraiment solide que la
russie n'exploitera pas cette situation
pour essayer de descendre des marines
sur la côte sud de l'ukraine parce que
il est clair que la russie a toujours
des vues sur la région d'odessa la
région de mikolajki la région des
personnels occupe déjà et donc je pense
qu'on peut comprendre que les ukrainiens
sont très inquiet par allah par rapport
à la possibilité de s'ouvrir des
vulnérabilités en terme de défense et
donc c'est c'est ce qu'elle réclame
c'est que c'est c'est des garanties
sécuritaires qui pour le moment je pense
qu'elle n'a pas vu de proposition des
garanties sécuritaires satisfaisante en
tout cas les réactions au ministère des
affaires étrangères à la réunion
d'aujourd'hui était plutôt juste de
souligner qu' il n'est absolument pas
question de croire les russes sur parole
et aussi il disait que quand les russes
dit que c'est la faute à l'ukraine que
le parquet les ports sont bloqués que
c'est que c'est des monstres à bleu m'en
faut division vrac les russes quand il
affirme effectivement que les ports sont
bloqués à cause des ukrainiens c'est un
petit peu vinolas difficile de négocier
avec quelqu'un avec l'adversaire
lorsqu'il dit cela mais évidemment et je
comprends parfaitement que les sucres
avec quelques raisons de se méfier des
déclarations des dirigeants russes donc
c'est pourquoi il faut revenir à
peut-être le seul point positif de la
journée c'était de la journée c'est à
dire le cadre de l'onu si des garanties
y compris sécuritaires militaires sont
fournis dans le cadre de l'onu alors il
ya peu de chance je ne dis pas une
impossibilité absolue parce que on sait
que poutine est à un mètre du mensonge
et de la toxic à sion mais pour autant
si l'onu est véritablement partie au
dispositif le plus concrètement possible
si un centre de commandement et
d'observation est installé à istanbul
alors ce sont quand même des garanties
qui sont probablement acceptable et les
turcs seraient prêts à accepter ce type
de garantie non seulement il acceptera
mille le favorise un parce que encore
une fois ça les remet au centre du jeu
diplomatique dont qu'ils accueilleraient
ces mesures et ce centre avec grande
diligence ça c'est une certitude
irene devrait vous êtes les réactions
peut-être à ce qu'a dit didier billion
est une solution tour de l'onu un
terminal à istanbul qui pourrait
garantir la sécurité des navires c'est
une piste celle qui me pisse mais ça ne
doit absolument pas être la seule piste
puisque tant que le la guerre continuera
en ukraine on aura quand même des
grosses incertitudes sur tout ce qui va
se passer là aujourd'hui il ya moins de
la moitié de la surface qui a été semé
donc la récolte ukrainienne il ne sera
pas au même niveau donc même si ils vont
rentrer des stocks on n'est pas au total
sur un marché mondial où on aurait la
même production que la production dans
le passé l'ukraine donc ça fait les
incertitudes face à ces incertitudes il
faut qu'on soit transparent aux minima
au sein de l'union européenne sur les
quantités de stocks produits et 10 et
habib est disponible de céréales
aujourd'hui on a par exemple viktor
orban de l'ami de marine le pen et de
poutine qui bloque les exports de
céréales en faisant ça il met une pièce
dans la machine à recréer des tensions
sur les prix de céréales donc il faut
vraiment qu'on ait des transmissions
mensuel des stocks de céréales privés et
publics y compris au sein de l'union
européenne de façon à ce que le temps
que les routes sécurisées se mettre en
place dans tout les cas nous ayons des
stocks concret pour les faire circuler
là où il y en a besoin hélas au sein de
l'union européenne ou sein des états
unis au sein d'autres pays à ma
connaissance il n'y a pas de problème
pour faire circuler les céréales et
qu'ils aillent au bon endroit
gulliver à ce qu effectivement l'onu
parce que vous disais que les ukrainiens
ont plutôt mal reçue cette rencontre ait
da en quarts à aujourd'hui est ce que
est ce qu'une médiation de l'onu et
quelque chose d'envisageable côté et
l'ins qui
oui je pense que c'est envisageable je
pense que c'est cette fois qu'il faudra
poursuivre mais très honnêtement
l'impression que j'ai eue en ukraine
c'est que tout le monde dit klassen
moyens le seul moyen d'exporter tous ces
céréales c'est par la voie maritime et
qu'
il ne pense pas que ça va être possible
dans les semaines qui viennent je ne
sens pas un trop grand optimisme en
réalité on ne traîne par rapport à ça
peut-être qu'on va avoir une surprise
mathieu brin donc aussi on en revient
justement si en tout cas y'a pas de
déblocage
la situation ne va faire que qu'empirer
en termes de prix en terme de pénurie à
un moment donné également sur le blé
absolument sergueï lavrov nous parle de
responsabilité éthique de l'occident
dans cette situation mais on est
vraiment dans un an dans un jeu de
miroirs dans un jeu de dupes qui a c'est
assez extraordinaire là on est vraiment
si on continue à bloquer comme je
voulais dit il y aura les nouveaux flux
de céréales qui vont qui vont arriver ça
va engorger les marchés il y aura des
conséquences très importantes sur les
prix des matières premières à court
terme et je n'oublie pas non plus la
question des engrais qui aujourd'hui
sont des êtres des éléments extrêmement
importants et qui limite la capacité
notamment sur les onglets les engrais
donc son ukrainien les engrais sont son
produit grâce au gaz au gaz russe et
sont majoritairement aussi en grande
partie en d'origine russe et donc les
pays d'afrique subsaharienne ont besoin
notamment de ses de ces engrais mais on
a aussi des prix qui sont extrêmement
élevés pour les agriculteurs français
également ou ou aux européens et donc ça
va m si vous voulez la planète agricole
dans une situation de surchauffe
extrêmement préoccupante pour les mois
prochains pour les mois à venir et pour
les prochaines récoltes l'année
prochaine en
23 donc cette arme en fait auquel ne
renonce pas la lumière poutine on voit
la certitude qu'il crée à la fois sur
les marchés et puis dans le monde global
ça c'est son arme c'est son âme à ce qui
est très important c'est que par
hypothèse si nous parvenions à un accord
c'est à dire la mise en oeuvre de deux
convois maritimes permettant de sortir
le blé ça serait évidemment un pas
concret le premier pas concret tangible
à l'envers un processus de négociation
c'est pour ça que ce dossier agricole
seul aux 6 10 et khalid est extrêmement
important il est plus que le dossier des
céréales parce que tôt ou tard et le
plus tôt sera le mieux il faudra bien
négocier aujourd'hui ni poutine ni ales
hemsky pour des raisons différentes un
jeu trace pas un trait d'égalité entre
les deux fonds non pas de la surenchère
mais se refuse à se mettre en position
de faiblesse c'est bien logique c'est
bien normal c'est le jeu diplomatique
habitude mais nous savons par ailleurs
qu'il y aura impérativement la nécessité
d'une médiation et d'une négociation car
il n'y aura pas de solution militaire
pour la donc ce dossier céréales et il
est peut-être le levier pour d'autres
initiatives de paix voulait réagir très
rapidement et rental ray oui un mot de
conclusion sur ce que vient car didier
billion un oui parce que l'union
européenne
et la réagi l'histoire des engrais on
est en train comme on avait fait pour la
codi d'un de déployer une filière
engrais dans l'union européenne en
profitant d'ailleurs pour aller vers une
filière décarbonée ce qui veut dire de
la coordination au niveau de l'énergie
la leçon qu'on a c'est que quand on a
des dépendants sur des matières critique
agricole et bien c'est hyper dangereux
quand il ya un risque politique donc
c'est le sont là ils sont liés il ya
beaucoup d'argent qui ont été mis pour
aider les agriculteurs européens et y
compris la flexibilisation
d'origine dettes d'état donc on est au
rendez vous de ce côté là parce que la
pac existe parce que la commission
européenne existe et que on a un petit
peu les leçons de la crise merci d'avoir
été avec nous il règnerait merci
beaucoup monsieur brun d'avoir été avec
nous merci didier billion merci beaucoup
gulliver accra vous était avec nous à
kiev et puis merci à ludovic d'olive de
foucauld qui étaient avec nous il y en
direct d'ankara au début de cette
émission merci à vous tous de nous avoir
suivis et reste avec concerne pas le cas
[Musique]